today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
alright so yesterday was day one of the
democratic national convention
i did a live stream of the entire thing
i was commenting i was reading viewer
comments as it was all going on
and um i i don't know
how else to start other than to say it
really wasn't very good now i'll talk
about
what expectations are and how it
compares to expectations and to what
we would expect from trump and i'm going
to contextualize it but there's no way
that i could come to you today and say
i'm so inspired and invigorated and
energized by what we saw
yesterday i sent some
early tweets like during the first half
hour
which were really quite negative i said
first off quote
i could have done without the prayer to
jesus to kick off the dnc
not sure about anybody else and i get
that everybody does it and joe biden's
catholic and there's still a pretense
about
religion in the democratic party and
it's not just necessarily a pretense
there are religious people as well and
that that's fine
um they do the pledge of allegiance like
it all just smelled
at this point like republican light
which maybe is the goal and arguably is
still a big part of the
the centrist elements of the democratic
party so i'm not acting surprised by
that i'm just saying
it didn't really resonate with me then
sort of about 20
22 minutes in in fact i said someone
please talk me off the ledge i want to
win and the first
22 minutes of this dnc i'm scared
can someone tell me how great this is or
something but
you know then it did start to improve
and maybe my view was skewed by the fact
that i just hate cliche
packaged politics and that's exactly
what the dnc
the democratic national convention is
designed to be it's designed to be a
package
culminating with the nomination of in
this case
joe biden in 2016 26 2012 different
people
uh to get to the election and
it's a package and especially when
you've got coronavirus
so it's not just the idea of packaging
up a candidate and a platform
but it is quite literally a video
package that has been pre-produced
in combination with live segments you
have no crowd
energy it might be just as bad with the
republican national convention and this
may be just what it is
but it felt very low energy and you know
they'd have an
actual okay speech and then they'd cut
to music or some other kind of interlude
that didn't make sense and took energy
away
but i want to try to really see this as
not
my reaction you know maybe this is the
right thing
like they don't need to convince me i'm
already voting for joe biden
and i actually don't even understand
being undecided
at this point and so maybe this is about
a very sort of polished
inoffensive package meant to
appeal to the few people that might
actually be unsure about who to vote for
like i don't know
is the point but given the opportunity
for democrats to do something knowing
republicans will also have an
opportunity to do the same thing next
week
i'd rather have the better convention
than the worst one no matter how much it
really matters
in the end now it did keep improving
during the first two hour during the two
hours of the first day
i thought the best parts of the evening
were a woman named
kristen urkisa whose father died of
coronavirus
after voting for donald trump she spoke
really well
and authentically and a lot of the stuff
felt inauthentic
she was really good and then from the
big names
listen bernie was excellent bernie is
always just so clear
and precise with his message and the
stakes and
i like that bernie spoke specifically
to his supporters from both 2016 and
2020
and talked about the importance of
voting for joe biden
this time around because of the
existential threat that is donald trump
let's look at like a minute of that my
friends
i say to you to everyone who supported
other candidates in the primary and to
those who may have voted for donald
trump
in the last election the future of our
democracy
is at stake the future of our economy
is at stake the future of our planet
is at stake we must come together
defeat donald trump and elect joe biden
and kamala harris as our next president
and vice president my friends
the price of failure is just too great
to imagine thank you
so really nice job by bernie sanders
beautiful aesthetics by the way also if
you were watching
uh bernie came to us from burlington
vermont with a nice wood pile in the
background i mean just very very
uh aesthetically pleasing as well i'm
half kidding i mean it was cool i don't
actually care about that but
seeing the wood pile was nice and then
michelle michelle obama was was really
very good she
closed off the night um i thought maybe
she went a bit too long which i was fine
with
but i could see from people in the chat
that some were starting to sort of tune
out a little bit but
i thought she was excellent fantastic
speaker and again check out this clip
from michelle obama
going into this idea of does my vote
even matter
michelle obama making the case very
strongly that yes it does
i've said before being president
doesn't change who you are it reveals
who you are
well a presidential election
can reveal who we are to and four years
ago too many people chose to believe
that their votes didn't matter
maybe they were fed up maybe they
thought the outcome wouldn't be close
maybe the barriers felt too steep
whatever the reason
in the end those choices sent someone to
the oval
office who lost the national popular
vote
by nearly three million votes
in one of the states that determined the
outcome
the winning margin averaged out to just
two votes per precinct two votes
she took that head on really really well
so
i think maybe what i needed was like an
attitudinal adjustment
you know how should we be thinking about
this does it matter
as i've said before i don't need
conventions this year i don't need
debates this year
but if we are having them i would rather
joe biden have the better convent
convention rather than the worst one and
we'll see how that continues tonight now
donald trump next week is planning to do
his
at the white house it'll have apparently
more of a live
feel than the very pre-produced
feel that the dnc had at least on day
one
my guess is trump is going to put
together
some kind of in-person crowd that would
be my my guess
now with coronavirus you've got to be
safe you can't do a big thing
packing an arena with 20 000 people
would be crazy
my idea for the speeches
for bernie and michelle and biden etc
for those speeches
i would have instead of doing like 30
short segments as they did yesterday
i would have given the keynote people a
little more time
but made it higher energy by putting
together some small
safe mass wearing socially distant
crowds
outdoors i'm not saying bring i'm not
saying do anything unsafe
but i think we could have gotten more
energy without
increasing the risk of coronavirus with
some small outdoor crowds bernie's crowd
in burlington that's fine
uh michelle's in dc or where you know
wherever they're living or at this point
uh showing the importance of mask
wearing
showing the importance of space but it
would have brought a little something a
je ne sais quoi
that was definitely missing yesterday
that would have been my preference
nothing unsafe
uh we will see how night two goes and i
will be streaming starting about 15
minutes before
the start of day two tonight on uh
youtube
twitch and facebook and i hope that you
will join me there
donald trump received some of his best
polling in a while yesterday there's a
major new poll from cnn which has joe
biden
only four points ahead of donald trump
with the margin of error that could mean
trump is now
straight up winning this is one of the
closest polls in a while
it's not the only one that says the race
is this close
but it should be a huge warning to
anybody who thinks joe biden has this in
the bag
especially if you thought yesterday's
first day of the dnc
was not so good then we have nothing
to sit back and uh be complacent about
if we look at recent national polls
cnn now has biden only plus four and
otherwise it's a bunch of biden plus
seven
biden plus nine biden plus ten other
than a harris x poll from a week ago
which agrees it's biden
up by four now if we look at this cnn
poll more closely
you will see that the margin of error is
3.7
okay so that means that
the poll says this is not speculation
instead of 50 biden might only have 46.3
instead of 46 trump could have 49.7 so
this poll if you read it correctly and
understand the margin of error
the poll says that right now trump could
be up by 3.4 now i don't need to remind
you that in 2016
hillary clinton had a lead of three in
the national pulse
and she ended up winning by two from the
standpoint of the popular vote and lost
the electoral college as michelle obama
astutely pointed out yesterday this is a
poll which says
forget about whether biden is up three
or four
trump could be up three nationally right
now
this poll outlines a better situation
for donald trump today
than he had in november of 2016. now
it's one poll the average lead for biden
remains just under eight points but why
would we take any chance
the polling is looking more and more
like it did in 2016.
anyone thinking this is over needs to
check the facts and the facts are that
not only is the polling tightening
between biden and trump
trump's approval is climbing i i know
that
when we think about facts and reason
it is crazy to think that this would be
going on but we live in a country
where more than 60 million people voted
for the guy in 2016. so we have to
expect things that make no sense
and if you look at the gallup trump
approval tracking poll
you see that after a huge drop in
approval during the earlier phases of
the coronavirus pandemic
donald trump's approval has slowly but
surely
started to creep back up from a low of
38
back in uh whenever up to 39
40 42 and the trend is pointing
further up now we can debate why this is
happening
some people are falling for trump's bs
they're just falling for it uh
we have a crazy situation that has been
normalized to some degree and people
have gotten used to the pandemic
and used to thousands of people dying
every single week from coronavirus
there are some people that are just dumb
okay well fine that's some p
it doesn't matter that's the thing they
get to vote and we get to vote
our focus needs to be getting out the
vote
and making sure that we vote this is not
if if you looked at biden plus 15 in an
outlier poll six weeks ago and thought
this was going to be easy
this is not going to be easy this is not
going to be easy two and a half months
to go
we could see anything happen between now
and november
trump teasing he's going to pardon
someone major today who knows what that
is
he mentioned he said it's not snowden
today but he's now thinking about
we don't know how different elements of
the electorate could react
we have no control over it we only have
control over our voting
and talking to other people about the
importance of voting let me know where
you are
on this polling issue on twitter where
you can find me at deepakman
and remember that august 23rd is
the 15th anniversary of the david pakman
show
on that very special day we will be
sending out
a coupon code via our newsletter
with an insane possibly illegal
certainly immoral
membership discount that you can take
advantage of just get on our newsletter
free at davidpakman.com the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day who
recently signed up at
joinpackman.com are jenny sebastian
and peter wells jenny and peter thank
you for your support
and george sutton is today's long time
sustainer of the day george has been a
member for almost
five years grab a membership it's quick
it's easy
it supports us at joinpackman.com
donald trump this week as a sort of
counter programming effort to the
democratic national convention
is traveling each day to different parts
of the country
yesterday he was in wisconsin today i
believe he's in
i think iowa and maybe arizona um
and yesterday specifically in oshkosh
wisconsin
he showed up did a sort of rally-like
event i covered it live
and trump simply collapsed once again
into authoritarian daydreams
authoritarian nightmares really saying
he would seek a third term
as president because his first term
maybe shouldn't count
i guess because he was spied on as he
claims even though of course that is not
the case
take a look at this insanity and
remember it might be a joke to you and
me
we might see this as obviously the
rantings of a lunatic but a lot of his
followers agree
with this idea we are going to win four
more years
and then after that we'll go for another
four years because
you know what they spied on my campaign
we should get a redo a four year
now obviously it's an insane idea
but trump got this insane idea from some
right-wing commentators who started
floating hey you know listen
trump didn't really get a first term
because they spied on him
and they impeached him and they did the
russia investigation
trump heard the idea so he floats it and
now his followers cheer
and some of them support the idea of a
trump third term now of course trump
will get no third term
nor will he run for one but this is how
wildly authoritarian stuff spreads and
it is spreading
some pundit puts it in trump's brain
trump at some point
manic from the crowd cheering floats it
and then you've got to
start hearing from his followers who say
this guy deserves a third term
because he didn't really get a first one
now everything about this appearance
was disturbing trump was very manic
throughout
uh it actually got so bad that trump
started talking about trying to win the
state of new york in november
it was so crazy that even fox news had
to cut away
again check it out for republicans you
have to run the whole board
because they start off now we're going
to play for new york with all of the
crime in new york i'm going to play for
new york
that was president trump speaking live
wisconsin and an airplane hangar uh
calling it a peaceful protest
not a traditional campaign rally really
zeroing in on joe biden saying he's
bossed around
now biden is up 24 in new york right now
trump only has 32 percent support in new
york
there is of course no chance that donald
trump wins
new york trump can certainly win and he
can win re-election
but donald trump is not winning new york
and then trump
absurdly claims that the united states
has coronavirus numbers
that are better than almost all
countries
it's difficult to imagine a less
accurate statement
and then trump says the reason you
haven't heard that
is because the media he points to the
back of the room always the media won't
tell you that
they released it they didn't release it
in china but it came to the united
states and europe 188 all over the world
188 countries all over the world we're
not going to forget it
we're not going to forget it but we're
doing great coming back we're coming
back and our numbers are better than
almost
all countries i will tell you that
despite what you hear look at all of
them up there
scott look at all of that fake news it's
unbelievable
unfortunately fox has become fake news
too i don't know what happens to these
people right
do you agree trump even turning on fox
news there which i'm going to talk about
more tomorrow
saying fox is fake news but that that's
optics i care about numbers trump said
we're better than almost any country on
coronavirus just as a reminder
we have the eighth most cases per capita
and the 10th most deaths per capita
out of more than 200 countries and
territories
those are the numbers then trump went
back
to his terrible reading of a poorly
written speech
and with 170 000 dead americans from
coronavirus trump says of joe biden
joe was bad on swine flu take a listen
look at all the fake news isn't that
incredible
there are a lot it's a lot of fake news
back there scott
at the end of joe biden's eight years as
vice president nearly two million
americans a prime working age had
dropped out of the workforce
our factories were stolen our country
was doing lousy
he lost nearly 200 000 manufacturing
jobs
he was by the way a disaster
on swine flu he got a horrible rating
in gallup look at the gallup poll look
at the gallup poll so they call it
h1n1 right do you remember h1 swine flu
h1n1 he calls it by the way um
just to be thorough out of curiosity i
went and looked
at the obama biden approval on swine flu
in 2009 about two-thirds of the country
approved of the job they did across all
regions of the country
across all levels of concern about swine
flu
so even there trump is wrong on the
facts and of course
is talking about something completely
unrelated to what is pressing now
which is 175 000 really
dead from coronavirus with 55 000
additional likely based on looking at
excess death data
and then strangely donald trump says
chicago is worse than syria
that that's the argument i mean you
probably find it odd
but he said uh chicago is worse than
syria and iraq
the context was of course bragging about
how he militarized our streets
the drawbridges to prevent hordes of
rioters from
ransacking the city can you believe it
can you believe it
17 officers were injured in chicago
they had a week a little while ago
during a weekend spree where 78 people
were shot
and 18 died that's worse than
afghanistan which we're getting out of
that's worse than iraq which we're
almost out of that's worse than
syria which we're out of except we kept
the oil but that's okay we'll have to
talk about that
chicago is worse than syria and iraq
this is all really bad but the seeking
the third
term thing is being weaponized and built
up by his most deranged followers
and this is a presidency that is a
testament
to ignorance the fact that he received
63 million votes in 2016
when running on things like fixing trade
and dealing with china
which he obviously has no clue of it was
a completely
obviously unsuited candidate to the job
but 63 million voted for him and it's a
testament to ignorance
the fact that he failed at everything
during his presidency most acutely
coronavirus
and is back up to polling 42
in the latest gallup presidential
tracking poll is
a testament to ignorance and then
the fact that he floats something as
authoritarian
as a third term while sending
militarized troops to cities
and kneecapping the post office to try
to prevent vote by mail
that is a testament to ignorance and to
people's
own sort of tacit
approval or indifference to the
authoritarianism
they claim to oppose so we're in real
trouble
and we're in trouble as far as the
absentee ballots as well that's what i
want to talk about next
as i told you guys some time ago i
requested an absentee ballot in the city
of boston i requested
one for the september 1st primary and i
requested one for the november 3rd
general election and in fact both my
girlfriend and i
sent our applications on the same day
two weeks ago to the city of boston what
was really weird was that within
five days she had her absentee ballot
already back and was able to fill it out
for the september first
primary and i figured oh i'm guessing
mine will get here the next day
and it didn't well it's probably just
one more day
maybe i missed the day's mail with my
ballot and it's going to be lit
delivered to me tomorrow boston's really
small you know three miles gets you
almost anywhere in the city proper no
big deal can't imagine it would be much
of a delay
well my absentee ballot didn't come in
for another day or two
i was away all of last week in the
bunker as many of you remember i figured
my ballot will definitely be waiting for
me by the time i get back right
got back yesterday still not here
started to find it strange now we're
only 13 days from the actual primary
my girlfriend got hers in five days
she's already send it in where's my
ballot
i call the city of boston city of boston
elections department explains
and they they say oh yeah we got yours
today
meaning yesterday right august 17th
but i sent it on august 2nd that's
15 days and my girlfriend sent hers
on the same day how did my ballot end up
delayed two weeks
when we sent our applications out on the
same day and the woman at boston
elections says
it's because here we go now it's because
of what's going on with the post
office two items
letters with a single you know just a
single didn't have to stamp it but
you know just a standard letter not a
package
sent on the same day could be delivered
more than 10 days
apart now much the same way
if i get the ballot today or tomorrow
and send it
could it again be delayed 14 days is
that conceivable
if so that will be after the september
first primary will it still be counted
it's certainly supposed to be counted
but if the city of boston assumes
ballots won't take more than two days
here in boston because again
it's a three mile wide city and then
four days go by after the primary
maybe they say let's stop counting now i
can't imagine any more ballots are
coming
in so this is truly a mess and remember
this is all by design limiting overtime
hours
so that even though my application and
my girlfriend's application
probably arrived to be sorted on the
same day
if you prevent overtime you prevent
sorting which prevents the ballot from
being handed to the carrier
which delays delivery and in this case
it delays processing
this is no joke and if this is happening
in massachusetts just
imagine what is going on in places with
inferior social services
and inferior infrastructure in general
so needless to say
my plan is to drive my ballot to city
hall
in the next few days assuming it comes
in today or tomorrow
now will this lead to protests because
they actually seem
warranted this is a major direct attack
on the democratic systems we thought we
had at their core
people emailing me saying you know david
i looked up my ballot
the online system says my ballot was
sent 10 days ago
haven't received it my town's even
smaller than boston it's two miles wide
or whatever
i hate to say it but to have more
certainty that your vote will be counted
you might have to vote in person and
given the pandemic that's horrible and
everybody needs to figure out
what's best for them what level of risk
are you willing to tolerate i wish i had
better news
but i don't but i don't we're going to
have more coverage of this
on our instagram page david pakman show
all one word on instagram
while you're there follow me on
instagram at david.pacman
we'll take a quick a quick break and be
back right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
uh today i'm welcoming to the program
barbara freeze who's an
environmental attorney energy analyst
and author of the recently released book
industrial strength denial eight stories
of corporations defending
the indefensible from the slave trade to
climate change
uh barbara it's great to have you on
today thanks for having me david
so this is this is a theme this idea of
denial it's a strategy really
and uh whenever there is a disagreement
in culture in politics wherever uh
sometimes the facts are debated but
sometimes
you see a strategy of of simply simply
denying the fact
saying those are not the facts or i
don't believe what you were presenting
me
uh sort of an equivalent to bearing
one's head
in the sand as it may be how far back
does the sort of grift of denial go as
you've charted and researched it
well i went back as far as the slave
trade
and a challenge to it in britain in the
late 1700s and early 1800s
i do think of this as a part of human
psychology so i think it goes back as
long as
as we've been humans but as as far as a
documented
industry campaign of denial we know that
it's at least as old as the slave trade
and what were the arguments made around
the slave trade
they were appalling and absurd they
basically
embraced this kind of rescue narrative
that
they were not uh you know enslaving
people they weren't taking captives from
africa and putting
them on horrible plantations on the
contrary they were rescuing them
from a worse fate in africa where they
would have been uh put to death as
prisoners of war
or eaten by cannibals and delivering
them to
you know first of all on a lovely
festive slave ship
to a very comfortable plantation where
they would be
well treated and have comfortable homes
and be taken care of
in in old age and sickness and it was
it was really appalling and because this
was the british trade and the british
dominated the trade
um they were speaking to an audience
that had no
direct experience at all of slavery so
they could really get away with with
some whoppers that they couldn't have
gotten away with in the united states
where
people at least saw something of slavery
i i've even heard
in the last few years that typically
from folks from certain political
persuasions in the united states
i'm not for slavery but conditions for
some freed slaves
were worse than with certain slave
owners which seems sort of like a
similar idea
well and in fact that was a strategy
that the british slave traders used
they frequently compared the conditions
that slaves lived under
with the poor in britain and of course
the poor in britain
did live under terrible conditions so it
was sort of an example of sort of this
downward ratchet that that as long as
there were bad conditions for one group
you could use that as an excuse
to allow even worse conditions for
another group
very present right now when we talk
about denial is is climate climate
science and climate science denial
and you you write about this in the book
i've been covering it for
a very long time is there something
unique to climate science denial
maybe either from a psychological
perspective or in some way that
distinguishes it from the other
denial grifts that you've covered or is
it just another version of the same sort
of thing
well pretty much all the climate denial
denials that we see have appeared
in other industries over the decades and
centuries but
there are some things about climate
denial that i think make it just
particularly
easy one of them is that it is such a
huge problem
it is such a long-term problem it is
something that
everybody contributes to at least a
little bit in terms of
consuming fossil fuels and that's such a
familiar thing that our minds are not
really
triggered to be afraid of of things that
are that familiar um
and another thing i think that that
makes this unusual is just the
phenomenal
success of climate denial i mean you
never heard
presidents of the united states at least
in the modern era
denying that tobacco caused cancer
but you have heard at least one of them
calling climate change a hoax
yeah that that's interesting because
some of the same people one of the
phenomena that i find interesting about
the climate
perspective climate issue is we know
what the science is and we know it's
overwhelming and at this point it's like
almost a cliche to repeat it time and
time again
but the people that deny it seem to
accept uncritically the claims
of some small sliver of scientists they
can find
or they in other words they seem to not
apply the same
critiques to those that happen to share
their
pre-existing notion and i've not found a
good way to break through that kind of
epistemological barrier when i talk to
those people
right one of the things i write about in
the book is basically tribalism and its
effect
on the mind and how easily triggered it
is
and then how incredibly powerful it is
so in times of uncertainty
in times of conflict uh it becomes
particularly strong
and certainly the the level of
skepticism
you would apply to people outside your
tribe
becomes very very high and the level of
skepticism you apply to those
within your tribe telling you what you
want to hear is very very low it's also
a sort of exaggerated confirmation bias
that we all indulge in personally
but that gets amplified in times like
this when the issue is this big
and when the industry in question
is really you know one of the most or
maybe the most powerful
industry in the world and where you're
talking about harms that are really
inherent in its central product in that
sense it's kind of like tobacco
um and you know interestingly the the
big oil companies now just like big
tobacco
don't deny anymore the fundamental facts
of their product causing harm
uh and yet they have been denying it for
so many decades and put in place so many
barriers to regulation
uh that they're still benefiting from
the decades of denial past
what seems to be effective in getting
through the denial i mean i'm thinking
of
you know with coronavirus as an example
initially when there were some cases in
china it was very easy to just say it
won't come here and then it did and it's
very easy to say there won't be a lot of
cases and they'll go away and then
there's lots of cases but you say well
we're not going to have a lot of deaths
and then there's deaths and then people
will say
listen i'm hearing that people are dying
but i'm not seeing the bodies and then
you see the
news video of the mass graves being dug
and the refrigerated trucks and people
say
that's optics produced to trick people
for political reasons like there
there's always that ability to
say it's stage managed it's fake
whatever
what is effective at getting past all of
that
i wish i could give you a formula that
that made it clear what's effective it
does seem to matter to have
facts and to have imagery and to bring
that before the public
um what tends to be most effective in
overcoming denial
is for there to no longer be any real
credible benefit
to denial so for example that's i think
what brought the tobacco industry
finally into you know the modern era
because
it was to the point where nobody
believed them anyway and they were being
sued for fraud and they had all kinds of
other
problems and they realized that
admitting that their product killed
people wasn't really going to prevent
them from selling it even after decades
of saying if this was true we'd stop
selling it
um so that tends to be what happens i
i'd like to imagine that eventually when
it comes to
larger efforts to overcome denial um
if if you think of us as being very
tribal and and taking on kind of a herd
mentality then perhaps when people who
are at
the head of the herd switch it might
lead to some
some greater acceptance you might look
at
the the george floyd protests which
isn't really the same thing but
but you had the video of his killing
right and i think that
helped a lot of members of the public
who had no financial or ideological
stake in this one way or another but
except that they wanted to believe the
world was you know better than it is
when they saw that i think a certain
amount of public denial about just how
bad things could be
went away so i i do tend to be a big
believer in evidence
uh and and trying to bring that out
there even though we do have a lot of
examples of it failing to convince
people
how much of a problem do you see uh the
corporate media coverage of some of
these issues being and this
the example i'm thinking of is although
the science on climate
is you know 99.98 to 0.02 or however
lopsided it is you you want to claim it
is it's somewhere in that range
you have numerous and regular corporate
media debates
where you have two people and they're
given equal time
and one person 50 of the debate
represents the 99.98 and 50
of the debate meaning one person
represents the .02
it's this sort of false balance problem
which i think corporate
media engages in in order to be
uh neutral as they say but neutral is
not objective and so i'm wondering how
much you think
that contributes to some of this denial
and provides cover
yeah i think that has always been a
problem when it comes to
particularly climate change i mean even
if you were to try to do it in some more
balanced way
and for example you were to have a a
debate with 99 climate scientists who
recognize the threat and one who denied
it
um i think that the audience would still
come away saying oh well then there are
two different opinions
so i i think you're right that pretty
much any attention to
what is now a very much discredited
viewpoint
gives it more credibility with the
public and particularly with the public
that is
not scientific and not fully aware of
all the data because you can never
really
convey all the data or or the strength
of it to a non-scientific public
when it comes to something like coal
which relates to the climate
um debate more generally
in that certainly you know if you
disbelieve
the science on climate you might be more
supportive of coal because of its
immediate
sort of monetary benefits in that it's
cheap and we don't need new
infrastructure like we would with solar
or wind or whatever the case may be
how have you seen or sort of observed
the coal debate happened during the
current administration where we've seen
the president
essentially say that he wants to take
take this
out of the market the free market of
course pointing to letting coal die
to revitalize an industry that from a
climate perspective doesn't make sense
where does this fit into the discussion
in terms of people who
who say yeah we should we really should
bring coal back is it a denial
of the climate science is it a sort of
political or tribal based reaction some
combination of the two
yeah i think it's it's certainly a
combination of the two and it's
certainly a reflection of the fact
that um to the extent the coal industry
has been defending itself in the past by
saying
that you should let the market decide
right that sort of ideological
justification for burning coal really
wasn't what was ever motivating them
and in fact what the president has tried
to do is to get
power companies to buy coal and and
subsidize coal
even when they would prefer not to so so
that was
um a pretty clear illustration
that the ideological justification was
never really what was driving
it the last thing i want to touch a
touch on is
i i think if we didn't mention this we
would be missing a huge piece of this
which is
the denial side is often very well
funded and when you think back to
tobacco and i forget if what if it was
the clean skies or clean
air initiative or whatever which was
basically about convincing restaurant
owners
hey if you want freedom from regulation
we need you on board so that people will
be allowed to smoke inside your
restaurants when the movement for no
smoking and restaurant started
these are really well funded movements
and that seems to dramatically
skew a lot of the conversations that are
happening does it not
oh sure i mean the industries that i
wrote about and i focused just on eight
industries and and most of the really
big ones
um they had an enormous amount of money
uh to promote their viewpoint to
give to other sort of free-market um
ideological groups to promote their
views more secretly
to hire people to to write articles but
not to explain where they got the money
um and then ultimately you end up with
an entire industry
that uh supports other industries that
are trying to be
trying to deny the science so you've got
the the law firms the pr firms the
advertising agencies
and these so-called non-profits that
that become advocates
uh to oppose regulations so i mean i
i try to write about this partly from a
kind of psychological perspective
looking at the social science and i
think what happens is that
for the the individuals in the
corporations that confront
these charges that there is a very
natural
instinctive inclination to deny it which
is
just part of human nature i think it
then moves pretty quickly into a
corporate strategy
and then it moves from there into its
own
kind of a denial industry with the same
pr firms and others appearing again and
again
and then i think it moves into an
ideology and and so it's that
progression
that makes denial uh this very human
thing
but but promoted by these very powerful
institutions
such a destructive thing do you have any
insights
into the psychology of the in the cogs
in the wheel so to speak
that are carrying out a lot of these
these denial campaigns because i could
imagine a situation where
the people working at the pr firm or the
people working at a corporation or the
law firm
at the individual level many of them
probably know that what they're doing is
lying and that they're denying
what what what are the facts is it as
simple as listen i'm a cog in the wheel
i'm just trying to put food on the table
and this is going to happen
regardless or have you had any insights
into that at the individual level
i think that is definitely part of it um
and corporations themselves especially
the big ones
are designed to make the individual not
feel responsible for what the
corporation does
it does that through division of labor
you're just a cog in a wheel and and we
know for sure that diminishes your in
your
feelings of responsibility for the
consequences
you've got management divided from
ownership
you've got this ideology that tells
managers that their only responsibility
is to maximize shareholder pressure
shareholder profit meanwhile
shareholders don't feel responsible
because they're far away it's
transactional they may just own the
stock for a little while and
they don't know what's going on anyway
we also know that power
tends to focus the mind on your most
salient goals which if you're in a
corporate executive is profit
it also there's some evidence seems to
reduce your
risk awareness and your risk perception
once you become aware of it and your
general
social responsibility again there's the
tribalism the competitiveness inherent
in
incorporations the market mindset so
yeah there's there are a lot of
psychological things you could point to
in fact i
suggest in the book that if you are a
super villain trying to get the world to
destroy itself
by taking crazy risks um you might just
create a society very much like our
corporate dominated market society
because there are many many things there
that undermine our innate sense
of social responsibility very well said
the book is
industrial strength denial eight stories
of corporations defending the
indefensible from the slave trade to
climate change we've been speaking with
the book's author barbara freeze
barbara thank you so much for your time
today thank you dave i appreciate it
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
dr anthony fauci is at least partially
blaming fox news host tucker carlson's
comments about him for the threats that
he and his family have been receiving
and this is another
really great opportunity to revisit the
concept of stochastic terrorism which
sadly shockingly is
quite prevalent during the trump
administration now you might recall that
we learned
a few weeks months ago about threats
against dr anthony fauci which is crazy
usually we listen to doctors during
pandemics in the united states they need
security
and the threats have in fact gotten so
bad that even
dr fauci's family including his
daughters are needing security now i
talked about that last week or the week
before
well tucker carlson has been saying
anti-fouchy
things for some time saying that dr
fauci is quote
an oily politician on an ego trip
tucker claimed masks don't do anything
tucker's against shutdowns trucker
tucker
trucker tucker has claimed he should be
a trucker rather than fox news host i
think we'd get actually a lot more value
given the importance of trucking rather
than him
seeding the country with bad information
he could be participating in delivering
key supplies but no i meant tucker not
trucker
claiming dr fauci has been quote
enjoying himself during the pandemic
and on and on and on carlson also
claimed
that the policies dr fauci was
recommending were
national suicide it's a very long list
dr fauci was asked about it he was
interviewed by the washington post
recently
and dr fauci said quote i'm not
concerned
about what he carlson says i think you
could say that when he does
that meaning talk about fouchy it
triggers
some of the crazies in society to start
threatening me actually threatening
which actually happens
who would have thought when i was in
medical school doing things to save
people's lives
i'd have to be going around with a
security detail
that's really ridiculous yeah
it does trigger people when tucker
carlson
makes dr anthony fauci the target of his
attacks and the relevant term is one
i've used before it's stochastic
terrorism
people often ask how do you spell it
that's s-t-o-c-h
stochastic terrorism this type of
rhetoric on fox news
can have a real world impact we we
already see the real world impact and
that dr
fauci and his family now need security
but it could lead to an actual acute
incident if you understand what i'm
saying now of course
of course tucker carlson wouldn't be
legally liable even if it was proven
that someone
attacked fauci and got the idea from
watching tucker carlson
why well number one tucker isn't saying
go attack dr fauci
but number two when we say stochastic
terrorism
we're talking about the idea that given
a large enough
audience it starts to become
mathematically likely
that someone will be moved to action by
the things that you say on the show
right so let's take something very
benign
if i on on the show every day say it's
really
important that people vote this election
no matter what
if my audience is 10 people it's not
super likely someone is going to go and
vote who otherwise wouldn't have
because of me my audience is a hundred
people it starts to become more likely i
will have influenced
someone to go and to vote who otherwise
wouldn't my audience is a hundred
thousand it's now
mathematically very likely that by
suggesting people vote i will have
influenced
someone so let's apply it to these
situations
imagine that there's a really small
chance
that tucker would be able to get an
individual viewer in his audience to go
and try to kill dr
fauci imagine that the possibility of
that is 0.00001
or something like that if tucker's
audience is 10 people
it's extremely unlikely with such a
small percentage
that anybody is going to hear tucker and
go and attack dr fauci
when the audience is a hundred or a
thousand or a million
millions of views on youtube it's still
not going to be many people but the
probability
that one person goes and tries to harm
dr fauci based on what they heard on
tucker carlson's show
starts to become greater than one like
it's likely to actually affect at least
one person and as you can see
once the audience is big enough the
irresponsible suggestion
that i could make or that tucker carlson
could make or whatever
starts to be likely to have a real world
impact we saw it with glenn beck and the
tides foundation years ago
where glenn beck was ranting and raving
i think at the time he was on fox news
about the tides foundation
and a guy an armed guy was actually
pulled over i believe it was on the
california highway on his way to attack
or bomb or do something to the tides
foundation now of course glenn beck was
not legally liable
but the guy said i got the idea that the
tides foundation needs to be dealt with
from glenn beck
is it easy to say well that's clearly
somebody who's mentally disturbed
normal people wouldn't do that sure but
the point is this stuff really matters
and for everybody who says merely free
speech and freedom of the press and all
of that yeah that's right
no one's denying tucker has the right to
say things about dr fauci
the same way that i have the the the
right to say people should go and vote
what i'm saying is you have to use your
speech responsibly and you have to
understand
that when you start throwing violent
attention on a doctor trying to deal
with the pandemic
you place a target on that individual
you're throwing gasoline on the fire
quite simply
and it's not about limiting speech
that's not at all what this is about
it's about recognizing that we have to
use
our platforms responsibly and of course
it's not just tucker right i mean if the
country were more educated
if the country less easily fell for
anti-science nonsense
tucker would be yelling into an empty
well but unfortunately
the american right is a particularly
receptive audience
for anti-science nonsense there are a
series of bills
popping up in a bunch of states that
would
criminalize and repress protests of
all types and this is really chilling
red alert authoritarian type stuff in
nashville tennessee lawmakers have put
together a bill
8005 8005 that senate bill and house
bill 8005
already passed the legislature would
make it a class
e felony to camp on state public or
estate or public property
between 10 pm and 7 am now what's the
idea there
the idea is have carte blanche have a
blank slate
to go after protests that will occupy
a plaza for some time or a park for some
time once 10 pm comes
classy felony start arresting everybody
they are threatening convictions
punishable
by up to six years in prison and the
possible loss
of your voting rights it makes it easier
to charge
protesters with theft if they mark up
state buildings with chalk
a michigan bill will classify
rioting as terrorism now what's the
problem there
uh the the line on
rioting is in and of itself up for
debate
this would make anything that you can
call rioting even if it's not
terrorism it would make acts of quote
social and domestic
anarchy punishable by up to 20 years
in prison or a 250 thousand dollar fine
in south dakota the governor signed into
law stricter penalties for
rioting and inciting a riot
now inciting a riot is pernicious since
animated protesting could conceivably
look like it incited someone to start
rioting
and that's a really broad catch-all that
is being applied there
in louisiana there's a bill on the table
which could mean
15 years in prison for protesting quote
on critical
infrastructure what's the idea there to
repress
protests near a pipeline that
residents in louisiana oppose now there
are many more examples more than 20
states over the last couple of years
have proposed
some of these types of bills the idea is
sometimes to criminalize homelessness
sometimes it's to criminalize protesting
other times it's to restrict restrict
speech in practice although they claim
that's not what they're doing in theory
and this is the stuff that reminds us
why we need to vote at every level it's
not just presidential but we need
state senates state legislatures
governorships because
those are the origins of a lot of these
bills and those are people
choosing many of the state judges
that might eventually decide on the
legality
of some of these authoritarian
restrictions on protesting
authoritarianism really does not like
protesting we know that from history
now i think it's also important to
remember
that this is not just about new laws you
can weaponize existing laws as well
which is why we need the right mayors
and police chiefs in place
mayors often choosing police chiefs
because
they can take advantage of existing
curfew laws
they can focus on unlawful assembly
angles
on gatherings and on and on so it's not
just about
state legislatures state senates and
governors we need the right mayors
we need to push them to select the right
police chiefs this is much more
than the presidency by the way
it's also really weird and of course
completely hypocritical
that many of the same people stockpiling
weapons
in case the government were to become
tyrannical
are in support of laws cracking down on
unarmed protesters honor saying
well if the gatherings are against the
law these protesters should find some
other way
to request redress of their grievances
what what things are completely
backwards
of course and this is just the latest
we have a voicemail number that number
is
219 to david p uh here's an interesting
question
about a word i've been using lately take
a listen
hi david uh this is mike from uh
washington state
i was wondering if you could answer a
question for me i hear
um you occasionally refer to
trump supporters as sick of fans or sick
offense
i'm not really sure what that means or
what that i kind of know what it means
but i don't really know what
you're saying is it sick of fans or
sika fans or you know
i'm not really sure what that term is
being said there so you could clear that
up for me i appreciate it i'll talk to
you later okay
so the term is sycophant okay it's
s-y-c-o-p-h-a-n-t
a sycophant is someone who acts
obsequiously towards
someone important in order to gain
advantage
or gain perceived advantage what does
obsequious mean
obsequious is to be obedient or
attentive
to an excessive or servile degree so
when we talk about trump's sycophants
we're talking about the people who will
go with anything trump says trump says
i deserve a third term because my first
one i had to deal with impeachment
they go with it they are completely
non-discriminating
in terms of what they will agree with
trump on and they do it
in order to gain some perceived
advantage either it's we want trump to
like us or it's to be part of the in
crowd or it's because
what our family and friends expect us to
do or whatever the case may be so the
word is sycophant
and often i like to sort of dress it up
by calling them
brown sick offense but maybe that's a
topic for another day
we've got a great bonus show for you
today donald trump is now lashing out at
new zealand's coronavirus response
on a day when new zealand had nine
coronavirus cases we're going to talk
about
new zealand because it's very
interesting what's going on there
we also have reported 130 degree
temperatures in death valley
potentially record temperatures coming
in death valley
and in california more than 3 million
homes
could lose power i will tell you why and
what's going on and we'll talk about
energy solar and much much more we've
got a great bonus show coming up for you
today get instant access to it
two ways become a member at
joinpacman.com
or become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i'll see you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video